[Music]  Khloe Kardashian is showing off her  incredible post-pregnancy body the new  moms workout routine appears to be  paying off  Khloe revealed she has already lost 33  pounds I feel sexy but there's nothing  like that revenge by the 34 year old  debuted her slimmer figure while  grabbing lunch wood boyfriend Tristan  Thompson at Joey in LA on Monday Chloe  looked healthy and happy in black gym  wear and a blush hoodie wrapped around  her waist while her mba probe Oh also  kept things casual in a black t-shirt  and blue shorts the new parents are  putting in the effort to make their  relationship work after Tristan  allegedly almost tore the two apart in  the days leading up to the birth of  their daughter true et has learned Chloe  and Tristan are taking couples therapy  since he was involved in alleged  cheating scandals  [Music]